the mausoleum of Ho Chi Minh the
founding father of modern Vietnam these
people are here to catch a glimpse of
his embalmed body to all Vietnamese
Uncle Ho is a great person I have been
here twice but today I brought my
younger siblings here to express our
gratitude and love to Uncle Ho he
dedicated his career in his life to
building this nation it's an honor to be
here to visit the mausoleum Uncle Ho as
he's affectionately known let the
Vietnamese nationalist movement for
nearly three decades first fighting
Japanese invaders then French
colonialists forces and later US troops
in the Vietnam War he died on September
2nd 1969 and did not live to see the end
of the war nor the reunification of
North and South Vietnam ho chi minh is
still very much revered in vietnam scene
as the man who brought independence to
the country but he's also viewed by some
as the source of authoritarianism the
Communist Party which he founded in 1913
still rules Vietnam to this day but over
the years the Vietnamese Communist Party
has slowly implemented reforms mostly
economic the country's growth is almost
parallel to China's a communist
one-party state that embraced market
reforms and capitalism in the early
1990s that policy has led to boom times
in Vietnam its GDP is forecast to
increase around six and a half percent
this year and next but alongside
economic success come new challenges
because we have development a lot of
people who have more voice more say more
representation they might not be happy
with one-party rule so you know Vietnam
Vietnam doesn't really have a civil
society but there'll be more dissent
there'll be more criticism howards we
had not managed that there's also
geopolitics to contend with China has
staked a claim in the South China Sea
building military installations on
artificial islands and occasionally
clashing with Vietnamese vessels
it's a delicate balance for Vietnam
standing up to a powerful adversary
who's also an important trade partner
and one-time ideological ally Ho Chi
Minh's communist teachings may not be as
relevant to the nation now but the
founding fathers sense of patriotism and
resilience are still alive
Florence lui al Jazeera Hanoi